good morning John I was just taking my
dog for a walk and I thought to myself
Hank you know what you should do today
you should blow John Green's mind so
that's what I decided to do John get
ready to have your mind blown so let's
start right here on earth earth is big
massive it's freaking huge it's so big
that we didn't even know how big it was
until like a few hundred years ago
that's not actually true people had
figured out how big the earth was a long
long time ago using math and being
really smart but we certainly haven't
mapped the whole thing I mean 500 years
ago Columbus was sailing around thinking
he was got to run into India because he
didn't know that North America was there
but John as massive as the earth is the
Sun it's much bigger as they might be
giant to have I'm sure informed you if
the Sun were Hubble a million earths
would fit inside so John I know I didn't
just blow your mind there's there's more
coming our Sun is very big in our galaxy
there are at least 200 billion of them
it could be as many as 400 billion turns
out not easy to count all the stars in
the galaxy I know I know I have not
blown your mind yet that is not even the
mind-blowing stuff the Hubble Space
Telescope is the most powerful telescope
ever created by humankind
I say humankind because by the in this
video you will probably think that there
are other large telescope wielding
species in the universe John right now I
am going to draw a dot on my hand doctor
okay you see that dot now I'm gonna move
that dot out here this is the size of a
piece of our universe that the hubble
space telescope was once pointed at the
scientists at NASA pointed that space
telescope at that tiny tiny bit of our
sky this tiny dot of sky was rare
because there was nothing there there
were no stars in our own galaxy there
were no galaxies that we could see there
were no nebulae or any smudge of
anything it was just a pure black spot
of sky now some people were like WTF
NASA why are you taking this extremely
expensive piece of machinery and taking
a picture of nothing with it but they
did it they pointed it at that little
piece of sky and they open the shutter
and they left it open for days they've
done it once before but now they've done
it again in December of 2009 it's called
the Hubble Ultra Deep Field when they
downloaded the picture that speck of
noting that grain of inky black
contained over 3000 galaxies galaxies
just like the one that our massive
planet takes up a tiny fraction of a
corner of a crevice every dot every
smudge every speck in this image is a
galaxy with billions of stars in it that
is a big universe and let me blow your
mind further by telling you that I think
that we have an important place in it we
don't know what's going on it took
humanity 99.9% of its existence to even
understand that we live on a ball of
rock circling a globe of plasma but you
want that video and you understand the
scope of the universe that understanding
the act of understanding I think is more
important in itself than the existence
of all star stuff in the universe people
have a lot of different reactions to the
knowledge that we are on a tiny pale
blue dot but that's mine I want to know
what yours is so leave them down in the
comments in my pants John I'll see you
on Wednesday